bonjour joël labbé bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france je vais vous poser
tout d'abord une question sur les
régionales temps de parole oblige delà
du csa ce sont les contraintes du csa
vous avez 1 42 secondes je voudrais vous
faire réagir à ce qu'a dit anne hidalgo
la la maire de paris a appelé à un front
républicain pour les régionales et pour
les présidentielles regarder marine le
pen c'est l'extrême droite
elle défend d'abord ses intérêts et les
intérêts d'une formation d'extrême
droite non républicaine et
anti-républicaine alors question est ce
que le front national pour vous et
républicains et est-ce que vous adhérez
à ce front républicain que anne hidalgo
appelle de ses voeux
par ap par exemple sous forme d'une
union de la gauche quand pensez-vous
vous avez 42 secondes
personnellement je le souhaite
cette union de la gauche et gauche et
l'écologie
je pense maintenant reste à savoir qui
peut en être le leader et je dirais
plutôt la leader dans le sens où c'est
ce serait plus une équipe qu'il faut
présenter pour les présidentielles que
c'est bien parti pour cette union de la
gauche vraiment pas vraiment du tout moi
j'en suis désolé il ya encore des
dissensions à l'instar de ce qui se
passe d'ailleurs chez les républicains
comment est ce que m sait que ça va être
compliqué mais mettre tout le monde
d'accord c'est un test d'ailleurs ces
régionales pour les présidentielles
selon vous de toute façon pour le pour
le premier tour des régionales s'est
pliée maintenant il ya les endroits où
il ya l'union et puis d'autres endroits
où il ya la désunion
ce qui est le cas sur la bretagne il
faut vraiment être vigilant parce que ça
peut ça peut faire perdre ce genre de
divisions
pourquoi est ce que cette union de la
gauche est extrêmement compliqué à
mettre en place selon vous il ya les
parties les appareils des partis les ego
de certains candidats qui veulent
absolument être candidat
je crois qu'il va être temps que l'on
dépasse cela étant donné la situation
d'urgence alors allez climatique elle et
pio diversité mais elle est aussi
politique avec un risque majeur
ma question sur le fond le rassemblement
national est il un parti républicain est
oui ou non selon vous pour moi non c'est
un parti qui existe qui représente d une
partie de la population
de plus importante d'ailleurs il ya un
gros risque le côté le côté républicain
est tout relatif avec les lois
successives que l'on a pour durcir la
l'appelait l'allier farce de police
notamment
il ya au risque de tomber dans un
totalitarisme qui pourraient arriver
assez vite si l'on n'est pas vigilant
on va en parler justement de cette
question de des policiers ils ont
manifesté à la semaine dernière audrey
pulvar son est émue elle a parlé d'
image glaçante gérald darmanin a décidé
de porter plainte pour diffamation
regarder les propos de madame pulvar
dépasse le simple cadre d'une campagne
électorale et viennent profondément
diffamé la police de la république je
porte plainte au nom du ministère de
l'intérieur
alors vous êtes d'accord avec gérald
darmanin ou audrey pulvar est ce que ce
sont des images glaçantes que nous avons
vu devant l'assemblée nationale
moi moi je n'irai pas jusque là mais il
y avait une file s'est passé des choses
de 2,2 pas nette entre le ce mixte entre
le entre la police et une partie du
monde politique
je trouve ça dommage et je crois qu'il
ya là encore il ya à renouer le dialogue
on a besoin d'eux on a besoin d'une
police
mais la police doit être extrêmement
réguler et encadrer et évidemment on a
besoin d'une justice qui soit forte et
juste par définition pour vous cette
manifestation est synonyme de scission
avec la justice
eric dupond moretti le garde des sceaux
a qui a été mise en cause d'ailleurs par
la police a parlé d' une police sans
justice c'est du totalitarisme écouter
la police sans la justice et le
totalitarisme la justice sans la police
c'est l'impuissance ces deux
institutions mérite le respect de tous
les républicains
la justice sans police mais ce que
vraiment il y à cette scission selon
vous il ya un écart qui se creuse entre
les deux institutions et je crois qu'il
ya urgence
am a évolué à surtout ne pas tomber
c'est vrai qu'il ya des violences qui
montent surtout ne pas tomber dans le
dos dans le too police pour avoir un
pays extrêmement impliqué et une juste
il la justice était essentielle pour mai
pour rendre la justice
alors on va parler de des violences
effectivement que vous évoquez avec
cette marche blanche à la mémoire des
deux adolescents tués en région
parisienne c'était samedi 1 pour 1
marjorie la maman de matteo d'ailleurs a
pris la parole au cours de cette marche
blanche regarde et je profite de cette
marche blanche en hommage à mon fils
pour essayer de montrer toute l'atrocité
et la souffrance et surtout les
conséquences qu engendre un tel acte
lorsqu'on perd son enfant assassiné
d'une lame de 11 cm en plein coeur il
n'y a pas de mots pour décrire ce que
l'on ressent j'ai une pensée
particulièrement aux familles
endeuillées comme moi par un crime
impensable et incompréhensible nous
sommes seuls à comprendre notre douleur
comment faire face à cette violence
selon vous quelle est calé les quelles
sont les solutions préconisées par par
votre parti écologiste par exemple alors
je suis sénateur écologiste je ne parle
pas au nom du parti écologiste puisque j
en suis proche mais je ne suis pas
porte-parole pour moi les solutions
elles sont à la fois de court terme et
de long terme et le long terme est
essentiel mais il faudrait prendre les
décisions rapidement remettre en place
une police d'une véritable police de
proximité
une police fait d' animateur de rue
également de telle sorte qu'on récupère
au ritz et palm os en se réconcilie avec
notre jeunesse qui quelque part se
retrouve avec deux montées de violence
et des jeunes qui sont de plus en plus
des structures et pour des raisons
sociétale et qui ont un passé derrière
eux ou pas de famille pas suffisamment
serré je crois que là où il ya un
véritable travail au niveau des jeunes
au niveau de la famille au niveau de la
présence policière
éducatrice de rue donc ça veut dire
passer par davantage de de travail
d'associations auprès de ces jeunes en
difficulté que vous nous décrivez
oui absolument on a perdu un temps
énorme de l'éducation avec l'éducation
populaire qui était véritablement un
socle delà de notre démocratie et de
l'apprentissage de la démocratie des
règles pour notre jeunesse
on a voulu ne travaillais plus que d'une
manière comptable le résultat c'est ça
on enlève d'aider des associations qui
jouent un rôle
le nombre de policiers et de moins en
moins nombreux au coeur des au coeur des
quartiers mais au coeur des villes
également
et là ça veut dire de la présence et de
la présence beaucoup plus préventives et
éducatives que ça ne l'est actuellement
j'imagine que votre raisonnement passe
aussi par une information au niveau de
l'école on a vu ces mamans qui ont perdu
un enfant
vous parlez aussi de l'autorité
parentale qui est mise à mal comment
faire pour rétablir cette autorité
parentale selon vous louis une fois de
l'autorité parentale est perdus c'est
extrêmement compliqué l'accompagnement
des familles là encore par par le tissu
associatif mais aussi par les pouvoirs
publics mais ça veut dire de l'argence
de l'argent enfin des moyens humains qui
coûtent certes mais ce sont des
investissements pour notre jeunesse dont
on a énormément besoin parce que la
situation de d'année en année se dégrade
alors il ya un rappeur qui a été
menacés de mort après avoir soutenu les
policiers il s'appelle chaotique 747
il dit que les rappeurs aussi ont une
responsabilité face à l'ultra violence
dans les banlieues qu'en pensez vous
est-ce que ça passe aussi par la culture
la culture c'est une évidence que ce
soit la musique la danse
l'ensemble des arts l'éducation
artistique 2 doit faire partie aussi de
l'éducation
évidemment des moyens pour les jeunes
d'assister à des spectacles et de de
s'exprimer également de des tas de
choses des cours de théâtre des cours de
danse où beaucoup s'en sont doués mais
livrer trop pas eux mêmes
alors oui oui oui il faut il faut les
prendre en main et donner les moyens
aussi à la culture là encore d'un point
de vue comptable
on est loin du compte mais la berd tout
autre sujet votre réaction à l'exercice
de communication du chef de l'état sur
youtube cancon avez-vous pensé moi ce
que je pense de ce type de communication
quelque part on est dans le bling-bling
on va on va draguer un électorat jeune
le choix du beaucoup plus profond que
cela
et il ya moyen de s'adresser aux jeunes
différemment maintenant maintenant il ya
de ce sont des choix qui sont faits on a
un gouvernement ultra moderne on va dire
qu'ils utilisent tous les tous les
artifices de la communication moi je
trouve que ça dévalorise la parole
politique je trouve
on va justement on va regarder un
extrait 1 je vais vous poser une
question par rapport à cet exercice en
regarde kylie ann m bape et c'est moi
qui m'occupe de sa carrière et donc
qu'il y ait même map et va quitter le
psg dans les prochaines semaines
pour l'olympique de marseille ça devrait
pas être annoncé comme ça là maintenant
alors que c'est un ce sera l'un des
transferts les plus énormes
ce serait le plus gros transfert puis le
mérite mcfly
est ce que cette anecdote est vrai ou
faux si monsieur le président
effectivement je suis touché de cette
anecdote je pense que cette anecdote est
fausse elle est fausse vos pensées on va
demander non oui bonjour qui viennent
c'est emmanuel macron à l'appareil
vous êtes en haut parleurs ça va ça va
super vous êtes en haut parleurs je suis
avec mac faye carlito là et on vous
adore killian bras volonté on vous aime
merci c'est incroyable merci de fou fait
un monstre
ça va très bien c'est un état
particulier si nous a fait rêver je sais
pas quoi dire
n'en faites pas trop non plus que non
c'est pas une interview c'est un
concours d'anecdotes vous parliez de
deux choses plus profond dont il
faudrait parler des problèmes de la
france notamment du de l'emploi des
jeunes par exemple bien ce qui bien sûr
est allé en parler directement sur le
terrain avec les interlocuteurs
là visiblement on a un président qui
s'amusent dans cette histoire ce qui
vous est ce qui a pour but de le rendre
sympathique auprès de la jeunesse je
trouve que vraiment là il dévalorise la
fonction de président de la république
payne là emmanuel macron turbin il est
depuis un moment déjà
alors on va parler de questions qui vous
touche évidemment de beaucoup plus près
c'est évidemment l'écologie la réforme
constitutionnelle sur l'écologie qui a
été enterrée et par le chef de l'état y
par les sénateurs vous pensez que ce
référendum pour inscrire les l'écologie
dans la constitution pourra voir le jour
on ne sait plus tellement il ya des
bâtons dans les roues des annonces des
contrats danse et lorsqu'on a voulu par
les deux pour l'état de garantir
l'environnement dans la constitution ça
allait trop loin
on n'est pas véritablement se place pas
véritablement dans la poste dans la
situation qui convient pour faire face à
aux urgences
et la croupe pour vous elle n'a pas tenu
sa promesse donc non celle là non parce
que il a il ya le gouvernement mais qui
aussi une majorité large à l'assemblée
nationale les les promesses il pourrait
les tenir et et après on se rend compte
qu'il y à ddd que la majorité allait
aller piloter et là aussi ça a été le
seul quelqu'un pour la démocratie moi
qui en appelle à beaucoup de plus de
parlementarisme la démocratie allait
elle est quelque part bafoués parce
qu'on a beaucoup perdu de pouvoir nous
les parlementaires alors il ya aussi
dans les tuyaux cet accord de
libre-échange controversé avec le
mercosur franck riester le ministre
délégué chargé du commerce extérieur a
été auditionné mercredi
il dit que ce traité du mercosur ne peut
pas être signé en l'état pour vous at il
une chance de ne pas aboutir je sais que
vous êtes contre farouchement contre
hélas ce qu'il dit peut pas être signe
en l'état ça veut dire qu'ils le il le
garde comme possible et par rapport à ce
qui se passe au niveau de la de la forêt
primaire des peuples qui vivent dont on
parle trop peu des petits paysans
brésiliens qui sont rejetés tout cela
pour le pour une agriculture au goût des
élevages industriels que nous ont
contribué à faire fonctionner sa en
important de la viande en important du
soja 80% transgénique
c'est à côté de la plaque par rapport
aux questions climatiques et
biodiversité et les je crois que là
véritablement sur ce type de traiter à
mon sens d'ailleurs il faudrait sortir
les productions alimentaires de ce genre
de traiter il est aussi une histoire en
bretagne vous êtes sénateur du morbihan
sur une liaison brest bélisle vente qui
va voir le jour une liaison aérienne
alors que les compagnies nationales elle
on réduit leur leur liaison à quand il
n'y a pas de solution en train à plus de
3 3h ou 4h
vous pensez que c'est judicieux d'ouvrir
une telle ligne entre une si courte
distance
non pas du tout je me suis aimé là
dessus parce qu'il ya pire
il ya entre vannes et belle-ile ça fait
pas faim oui ça fait pas 50 km et donc
ces deux lignes brest bélisle van belle
île et l'a véritablement ce sont pour
des gens qui ont de l'argent c'est pas
pour les affaires parce qu'on va pas
aider les pour faire des actes d
affaires sur une petite île comme ça
c'est se faire plaisir en s'offrant un
peu d'exotisme avec des avions privés
c'est pas du tout dans le sens de
l'histoire là parce qu'on demande
demande aux gens qui ont peu de moyens
qu'ils pouvaient prendre un peu l'avion
eh bien on dit non vous prenez le train
lorsque lorsque c'est possible et c'est
ce qu'il faut faire mais à côté de ça a
laissé se développer ce type de ligne là
encore c'est la france à deux vitesses
il faut prendre le bateau pour aller à
belle-ile j'imagine oui mais à travers
une lutte c'est une vingtaine de minutes
on peut améliorer la bla le réseau
ferroviaire notamment cette voie qui va
jusqu à quiberon pour prendre le pouls
reprendre le bateau mais l'idée d'aller
sur une île sans prendre le bateau c'est
un peu un non sens merci beaucoup joël
labbé d'avoir répondu ce matin à nos
questions sur arte france